[Music]
here's your money briefing for Thursday
July 6th I'm J.R Whelan for the Wall
Street Journal
Frontier Airlines has been promoting its
go wild pass that lets Travelers go
anywhere they want in some cases for
just a couple hundred dollars but what's
the catch Wall Street Journal travel
columnist Don Gilbertson recently put
the airlines all you can fly pass to the
test so Dawn first of all what does the
pass allow and not allow passengers to
do anybody who's tried to book a last
minute flight knows that those flights
can be astronomical you buy the pass and
then you can buy domestic flights a day
before and international flights 10 days
before so it's really for people with
ultra flexible schedules ah so if
spontaneity isn't your thing this might
not be for you oh 100 this is not for
you I mean there's an entire Facebook
group devoted to this pass and you can
just tell from going through it that a
lot of people did not read the fine
print so why'd you do this they were
Hawking it big time last fall and
they've continued to keep promoting it
as a way to fill seats last minute
especially during slower periods
obviously we're not in a slow period
right now so I just wanted to see how it
was going to work in practice and so we
bought one last fall the pass did not
kick in until this spring and I wanted
to wait until summer to really see can
you use this pass if you bought this
pass as a traveler can you use it this
summer and I was able to use it so you
use the pass in June how many flights
did you wind up taking I
have been trips uh it was nine total
one-way flights because I had a couple
connections just over the course of a
week and again my schedule was very
flexible I wasn't trying to go to a
wedding in Des Moines or catch fireworks
somewhere I went with an open itinerary
just to see where I could get to and
couldn't get to what is the past cost
and how does the cost of flying last
minute with the pass compared to Flying
last minute without it and having to buy
a ticket two things one the pass cost me
I bought it the annual one last fall for
599 that is no longer available the
annual pass now is almost two thousand
dollars but they also have a variety of
seasonal passes they have a fall and
winter one they had a summer one but
again you buy the pass and you also are
responsible for taxes on the ticket and
now the taxes aren't very much I mean
the most I paid for taxes I want to say
in an international destination was
about ninety dollars but one thing
people do have to keep in mind Frontier
you know like all budget Airlines is
very fee heavy so you know if you want
to take a carry-on bag and you want a
seat assignment you know the cost
escalates even if you have this passed
those things aren't free sometimes
booking Rewards or promotional seats
like this can be more difficult than
just booking a regular seat how is the
booking process for you exhausting
because I really wanted to test it out I
wanted to see where I could and couldn't
go and so I'd be on their website again
I did this on the Fly I'd fly in one
place and try to look for my flight the
next day and it's trial and error you're
on frontier's website and you're going
okay well here I am in Chicago where can
I get to tomorrow so it was exhausting I
mean literally in my notes everywhere in
my notes it says what a pain this is but
it's only a pain to book it but it's an
adventure that's what they're selling
here as an adventure if you're trying to
go see your kid in college and you have
one route and you only can travel Friday
to Sunday this 100 000 is not for you is
Frontier the only airline that has this
kind of unlimited pass right now they
have the most broad pass but Alaska
Airlines it's a well-known Regional
carrier I mean they've been expanding
across the country too they have a a
regional subscription plan JetBlue used
to have one the major airlines the big
ones uh have tried it in the past and
found for them it wasn't financially
feasible yeah you're flying all over the
country or the world's on a flat fee
yeah but for the airlines that still
have these passes well what do they get
out of it well they can fill seats that
might otherwise go empty you know even
in my case right I mean every single one
of my flights was full but how many of
those people on that flight were a gold
wild passenger like me so if you're
looking and you have you want to go from
Atlanta to Punta Cana in the Dominican
Republic that was one of the first
flights I took that cost me under a
hundred dollars because I was flying on
a Thursday morning and maybe there
wasn't a whole lot of demand for that
ahead of the holidays so you were one
person taking all these flights but for
somebody traveling with a companion or a
group what would they need to keep in
mind oh well if I had to find one state
you've got to find two three or four
seats first of all you also have to buy
the pass of everybody in your group I
can see like maybe a couple a young
couple that maybe Works remote or a
retired couple you know that just wants
to have this adventure and go then it
doesn't matter to them but you know for
a family that's just trying to go on a
couple vacations a year absolutely not
this is not for those kind of travelers
all right so we've heard from dawn the
travel columnist who booked seats and
flies for a living but for Dawn the
tourist and air passenger would you do
this again I would I mean I really would
but I'm here again Don the tourist here
I don't fly first class at all I don't
have a problem with Frontier again do I
want to do it every day absolutely not
do I want to do it cross-country for
hours absolutely not but I paid 5.99 and
I've already gotten nine flights out of
it I had to pay some out of pocket
obviously I could use this this weekend
I could get off the phone with you right
now and book a flight to Vegas that
would cost me fifteen dollars that's
Wall Street Journal travel columnist Don
Gilbertson and that's your money
briefing I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
[Music]
foreign